he says and in 2022 appointed a female
coach as as the European week of sport
Ambassador as a role model
to provide more evidence and address the
media coverage on women in sport the
commission runs a joint project all in
Plus
with the Council of Europe
finally the commission encourages
equality a safe environment and
inclusive sport through defending
priorities of the Erasmus Plus sport
actions
unfortunately when it comes to
gender-based violence there is no place
which is completely safe for women and
girls including in sport
despite some progress sexual harassment
remains ubiquitous in our societies
combating all four all forms of violence
against women and domestic violence is a
key priority for this Commission this is
why we welcome European Union's
accession to the Council of Europe
Istanbul convention
on preventing and combating violence
against women and domestic violence in
June 2023 last year
the European Union gender equality
strategy for 2025 recognizes the urgency
of addressing sexual harassment as a
form of gender-based discrimination and
violence
in European Union women also often face
sexual harassment at work
this has significant negative
consequences for the victims the
employers and workplace culture sexual
harassment is covered by the
international labor organization
convention
120 on violence and harassment in the
world of work
the European strategy framework on
health and safety at work acknowledges
the negative consequences of workplace
violence harassment and discrimination
whether based on sex or any other
grounds commission supports together
with European Agency for safety and
health at work awareness Rising on
raising on workplace harassment and
gender bias and calls on the member
states to promote gender considerations
in design implementation and Reporting
regarding legislative measures I would
like to recall that harassment based on
sex and sexual harassment
in the field of employment and
occupation and access to goods and
services are already prohibited under EU
law on gender equality in the area of
employment and occupation in March 2022
the commission proposed eu-wide rules to
end the gender-based violence against
women and domestic violence you are
currently negotiating this proposal with
the council I would like to use this
occasion to thank the European
Parliament for its constructive approach
to successfully conclude the
negotiations still under this mandate
which I believe is our shared goal
commission is furthermore proposing that
managers in the public and private
sector are obliged to receive training
on how to recognize sexual harassment at
work Provide support to victims and
respond in an adequate manner this is
not limited to physical sexual
harassment but covers all fours all
forms of unwanted verbal non-verbal or
physical conduct of a sexual nature
once directive is adopted in the member
states where sexual and psychological
harassment constitute a crime offense
victims of those forms of violence will
benefit
from the established measures on
protection support including targeted
support for victims of sexual harassment
at work and access to Justice the
commission remains fully committed to
upholding women's rights and combating
any form of violence against women
including sexual harassment thank you
very very much for your attention thank
you
thank you madam commissioner we start
now with group spokesman and the first
one from the Epp is
president
a few weeks ago during the celebrations
following the Spanish victory for the
world women's football championship
I think all of us saw firsthand the
disgusting reprehensible attitude showed
by the president of the Spanish Federate
Football Federation
who violated the dignity and rights of
all women
his behavior
reflects without any doubt the tip of
the iceberg when it comes to widespread
sexual violation which has existed for a
long time
this means that we have to roundly
condemn any form of violence against
women we have to eradicate this with
immediate and efficient responses
this is why it's important that we send
out an appeal to the whole Sporting
Community to ensure that they comply
with the Istanbul convention protect
prevent persecute and eliminate protect
women
prevent and persecute and eliminate all
forms of violence against them
the response from the whole of society
was overwhelming
the enormous support extended to Jenny
hermoso the world champion was generous
and impressive so I think subscribe to
Jenny
and all those who showed solidarity with
they've given us a clear lesson never
again should a woman be a woman be
forced to expect except
such degrading Behavior we have to fight
for equality to ensure that we have a
world of sport free from discrimination
and violence
so
it's we have to bring an end to we also
bought you Jenny
you've written history on the sporting
field but also when it comes to the
fight against equality for women in the
world of sport
I'm winding up
our society wants to ensure that our
leaders are show responsibility
hopefully there'll be unanimous support
for our calls for defending women
in the same way
as we saw the unanimity when it
comes to the support for the law in
Spain only only if I said yes say yes
Ms Regner on behalf of the s d group
thank you very much president
commissioner
uh when is a is unacceptable Behavior
that's a question that everyone
there is no consent for a kiss consent
is key and that's uh true for all uh
interactions people should have the
right to say yes or no and there has to
be a possibility to express one's well
only Yes means yes and that needs to be
clear whether that is at home behind
closed door or if it is a
in front of the cameras when Everyone's
Watching whether it's in the workplace
or whether it is in in the workplace the
um the case was uh unwanted but there
was no opportunity to reject that and
that is abuse
and I think the discussion has made
things clear to people what is a consent
the right of a woman to determine um
what happens to her body is no longer
um something which
it's a necessity thank you both of new
Europe Miss faring
president commissioner dear colleagues a
kiss on the mouth without consent is not
a mutual or consensual act no Mr
rubialis it's an unacceptable Act of
aggression fortunately this act by the
former president of the Spanish Football
Federation on Jenny hermosos was filmed
which made it possible for public
support to be given to the player
without that he would never have
resigned because he was protected but
how many
um aggressions are hit and how many
athletes are victims of abusive coaches
doctors managers how much pain is hidden
by Sports federations
but a sexual aggression is unacceptable
everywhere there but there is still a no
matter in sport right up to the top of
the Federation and it destroys men and
women legislation exists but it is not
respected it is up to us as
parliamentary to apply to put pressure
on sporting organizations like FIFA to
amplify the voice of victims to
encourage when women sport to promote
education about consent from a very
early age and to harmonize our legal
instruments because never again should a
man taint a victory by women
thank you very much uh next speaker on
behalf of the greens this is riba Eugene
thank you president commissioner
this has been a good Parliament as far
as the battle for gender equality is
concerned but let's be clear with still
an enormous amount of work to do the
non-consensual case between rubians and
Jenny hermoso shows how difficult it is
to put an end to violence and the
impunity both of which are structural in
sport we can put together laws promoting
equality in the world of sport as well
and that's what we should do the number
of players or female referees is still
vastly lower than men and the wage Gap
is unacceptable the best
player in the world Alexia bodegas makes
in a year what uh Panzer party in her
men's team would make in a month
it's also important that we have more
women in the sport decision-making areas
the Spanish Football Federation meeting
had only six women out of 140 members
and that's absolutely scandalous
a something which kept applauding the
matches reaction Macho reactionary
speech to Mr rubiales so we need to make
sure that high representations such as
the advantage Football Federation should
respect gender equality in its decision
making bodies and Mr Borel is not that
we're learning to play like men we are
learning to break the silence as Deborah
the football player said we've been
quiet for too long we had to listen to
an awful lot and put up with an awful
lot and now we are going to speak when
we feel like it and where we feel like
it thanks very much thank you says the
president on behalf of the ECR group Mr
books
thank you president commissioner let's
make it clear any form of violence
against women in sport
uh is carried out by men is permitted by
the fact that in many cases men are
responsible for giving them the cups and
so on some years ago the Spanish
Associates party changed the penal code
more than 1 000 condemnations 100 people
were released from prison for sexual
aggressives That's the Law you adopted
you put forward that law you voted on it
you adopted it you applauded it
and today women enjoy less Freedom
thousands of women and young girls are
attacked physically by sexual presence
in Spain everywhere 46 percent of people
condemned for sexual violence in two in
201 or foreign
they're strange enough when the
perpetrators are Spanish we hear Silence
from you because it doesn't fit in your
moral framework
so we've now seen this spectacle of an
obscene act a lack of respectful women
but you promote sexualization of young
women and children in schools
and we've seen examples where we have uh
people attacking young girls in Parks
who do nothing about this once again
because it doesn't fit in with your
moral framework which suggests that
people you have to destroy is white
Western man
it's true to say that women face a
danger the fact is this time around
we've got proof of it
for the left group Villanueva Ruiz
thank you president
it's over that's what these Venezuelans
players showed when they raised a banner
at the World Cup the women are showing
their pride and have made large numbers
of women and girls extremely proud and
wanting to follow the same path the
culture of rape and sexual
discrimination labor discrimination
silence impunity though all of those
things are now under attack a whole wave
of people women and men in Spanish
Society Society have said you can't have
sexual freedom without consent
we are now fully aware of that but is
still there are a lot of areas of
resistance rubiales
tried to pretend that it was consensual
and that's why we in all the
institutions need to work together to
make this a reality thanks to the
feminist movement and legislative
changes as which are part of the fight
where Spain is now a Pioneer we're still
making progress and that's the only way
it will then finally come to an end
thank you very much the next speaker
will be Mr jerusal
just imagine at the end of the Qatar
World Cup an Argentinian delegate tried
to kiss Lionel Messi on the lips what
would have happened
the fact that here in this case a
Spanish leader did this with a female
player
the problem at its root is cultural it's
we need to educate young children but
for mutual respect a full understanding
of sexuality and the sexuality of others
however we also have to address its
legal level
in Italy women only have a very short
period when it comes to reporting uh
rape or sexual crime just recently it
was just six months
the fact is that in some cases in other
countries women are able to report rapes
after many years the women have the
courage to face the trauma there's an
obligation in all member states in the
European Union to promote sexual
education of young people and to ensure
that there's a time limit of at least
five limits to allow people women to
report rapes and sexual harassment
otherwise we'll face further decades in
which rape and other forms of sexual
violence will remain unpunished
thank you very much Mrs Fitzgerald
no woman is safe from sexual harassment
not even a winner of the World Cup
what we witnessed this summer is a
reflection of the widespread disrespect
and misogyny faced by female athletes I
ask if this can happen in public for the
whole world to see just imagine what
happens in private and behind closed
doors
the arrogance the audacity the collusion
in full view of the world to see an
insult to women and to The Men Who
Champion equality in sport
what is now emerging is what many of our
top female and indeed male athletes have
had to cope with in terms of blatant
harassment and again the women misogyny
they've faced and demeaning behavior and
of course it is time to call whole to
this
what we have seen in recent years is a
wonderful flourishing of female sport
making up for decades of invisibility
and societal appreciation
thanks to terrific initiatives by many
in sporting organizations and indeed the
resilience of sports women themselves
however we still have a wage gap of 13
overall and media coverage this is hard
to believe are barely four percent
we still have huge work to do for women
in most sporting bodies at all levels
Administration coaching and amongst
players
future generations of young girls
deserve equal access to a safe
environment to participate in sport this
is the very minimum that they deserve
thank you
thank you very much the next speaker is
our colleague Mrs fritsonar
president Kim football
is at the largest dashboard in the world
and also the greatest expression of
culture wherever you go in the world you
can find a children who are wearing
football shirts and they're dreaming of
becoming
um a championship players and what we
saw was a professional athlete who in
her finest Hour was subject to an attack
and
this is what a lot of um women athletes
have been telling us and it's important
that we support a Jenny and all women
football players and we make sure that
we do everything we can to achieve a
change so that the young girls who are
now starting to dream
of
and discover the pleasure of football
that
they can have positive experiences
that's what our girls deserve and uh I
think the colleague Vasquez lazara is
not here
in that case let me give the floor to Mr
OTA soon
to sexual violence and aggression by Mr
Rubio should be condemned by this house
but also we also saw how the feminist
movement rose up in Spain and throughout
Europe and movement is more and more
necessary to say that they're no longer
tolerate such Acts actions which ended
up making Mr rubiares resign we've seen
all of the
Prejudice that exists in sport there's
now an attempt to achieve
wage equality which is a moment a
shameful thing that does not exist here
in Europe but there are still issues
such as maternity leave protocols
against harassment there's a lot to do
to protect female athletes against
discrimination as well as a
masculinization of the high instances of
power when you saw all these men
shamefully applauding Mr albionis in the
Spanish Football Federation meeting but
Jenny and the other footballers have
shown us an example in the whole of
Europe thanks to all of them thank you
thank you very much the next people will
be Mrs canco no means no President Van
dereland said in her speech yesterday
sadly this basic principle is still
something we need to fight for
I stand here today as a mother
as a woman
as a lawmaker working on the directive
and combating violence against women
I hope that together we bring closer the
day that now work places streets and
homes nobody needs to be convinced that
no means just no and the absence of yes
also means no we all know that the first
kissing is just the tip of the iceberg
of what women endure every day in many
places inside and outside the sports
walls whether they are on top or at the
bottom of the ladder but laws alone are
not going to solve this problem we must
all think about our daily habits men and
women yes men women can be your boss and
continue being who they are face it no
women it is not okay to play groupies
and pick me games be allies
who do you pick as allies when do you
look away only if we realize as
lawmakers that this is bigger than a law
will we be able to truly start changing
something and making our kids proud
thank you
thank you sir
thank you very much the next speaker is
Miss reago
gracias president thank you American
president
the image of a sexual aggression was
broadcast throughout Europe the
president of the Spanish Federation of
football
kissed without consent one of the world
champions
such an act
is clearly an example of sexual abuse
and abuse of power any doubt he
questioned that
this he was talking about something
which is now normalized in all spheres
of life I'd like to make it clear that
his Privileges and abuses
are something which
are quite normal
however this doesn't mean that for women
they should accept the fact that
somebody touches their ass in the
streets or that your boyfriend forces
you to kiss you or make love
however this is acceptable for many
people apparently what we're talking
about is sexual abuse this is a
privilege of men
who abuse and disregard our rights our
own bodies as we saw this recently
however the uprising of Spanish Sports
women shows it's now over we can insist
now on our rights to ensure that we have
the right to complete sport or the
safety also working and productive
politics in environments which are free
of sexual aggression
thank you very much
the next speaker will be Mr frankovski
sorry Lena Mr frankovsky is first sorry
the events in Spain moved to the World
of Sport I used to be a professional
footballer and I know the World of Sport
very well and it's pitiful that this
happened in a field where you should
normally have the values of equality and
Mr rubiales showed something totally
different than the ideals of sport but
that's not the only situation there and
one should see that violence in sports
remains to be a problem
violence in-depth football pitch and
outside the pitch that influences
negatively the image of footballers of
players in general it can hurt the image
of sport as as a way of portraying
positive things unfortunately there is
violence in clubs at the Ahmad future
level and particularly with respect to
team sports
we have seen in research that races and
discrimination are a common problem in
amateur Sport and in professional sport
therefore we should do the utmost to
draw conclusions from what happened and
make sure that this happens never again
my report from 2021 on the future of
European sport policy includes a number
of recommendations that should be put
into Force as quickly as possible at the
level of sport
federations and Sport must be free from
any violence thank you
thank you very much and now it's Miss
galvestonia
case isn't an isolated one it's actually
the normal way that
Macho's operate the opaque world of
football where there's so much money and
so much power since that all men they
still haven't understood what happened
women however do understand and we've
said
it's over
this on
welcome and unwanted kiss and
unconsented to kiss isn't something
which is part of
the male send mail-centered culture of
the West Mr book said a but it's also
something where women are know that this
is something that happens every day
there's now an awareness
raising going on a feminist movement
which is very tough and some of the most
advanced equality laws in the world and
Associates government which is building
an Institutional architecture and didn't
bow to the reactionaries of equality
this shameful incident has shown How
Deeply rooted feminism is in society and
how we continue to fight against the
people who try to stop this movement and
it's happening even though it's deeply
rooted in the world of sport it's over
thank you again thank you very much the
next speaker will be missed Rodriguez
Ramos gracias president thank you
president
members of the Spanish national football
team
had to win the World Cup for the world
to listen to them
and even in the past they've spoken out
many times for years they've faced a
situation of discrimination of
demeaning Behavior treatment
both on and off the field
so
the events during the World Cup
Celebrations wasn't just an isolated
one-off
that was simply an example of what
they've been living for a long time and
what's more many of the people
Washington TV live similar things in
their lives
political and sporting leaders in Spain
should have acted earlier if they had
done so
rubials wouldn't have had to resign he
would have been fired and all of this
wouldn't have happened
and
the fact is
future victories for the Spanish
football team
depend on its players
but it's up to us to ensure that we
don't have a rerun of what's happened
that night this is a Spanish woman
football team shirt several
Commissioners have signed it the
president interrupts
the present interrupts
so we have to call for zero tolerance of
sexual violence in sport
this is against the rules of the house
as you know and I would have to ask you
to refrain from
showing even if I like it uh this this
kind of symbols so
um next month
at the next speaker will be Mr fonkramon
traveled a president commissioner dear
colleagues
no means no
that's something that Ursa vandelion
said in her state of the universe which
is and so
um
rubella's case Jenny hermoso in front of
the camera she had no opportunity to say
no
um thousands of athletes said that they
had experienced violence in sport and
they weren't old enough to say yes and
most of the time the perpetrator wasn't
punished but the victim was um
threatened
good now in this parallel world of
international sport with
um corruption uh sexism we need a reform
we need a a safe International airplanes
with a clear mandate for the protection
of women and Punishment of um
those committing these acts
in politics as well far too many people
are looking away rather than dealing
with the sporting fan narration we need
to protect female actors
athletes and do as much as we can to
ensure the Integrity of sport and so I
call on you to support a female athletes
in their call for an anti-corruption
agency the next speaker will be Mr
wrestler
every Sportsman every woman needs
equality
deserves respect
female sport just as male sport is a
life of much work much suffering and
renouncing to many things in order to be
the best in order to be what you really
are but in order to have women and men
compete
and in order to be able to be um just
winners we have to say this openly they
need to be women many throughout history
wanted to have an easier way to success
by cheating or hormones or doping but
now
those who try to erase differences
between men and women are putting a new
uh
obstacles between men and women sports
they do are cheating and then they are
there to cause problems over women and
this is something that is degrading
Sports we have to protect the Dignity of
sport and the Dignity of female
Sportsman and we have to have
competitions without any ideological
whims thank you thank you very much the
next speaker will be Mrs marilio
foreign
commissioner what happened is a very
serious matter the act of Macho violence
is an abuse of power the physical
demonstration of how patriarchal culture
is still present in sport
all you need to do is think about the
recent abuse uncovered in uh women's
football carried out by trainers
unfortunately this is a problem that's
widespread one sports woman in seven
under the age of 18 says that they have
been the victims of sexual violence and
harassment often from their coaches but
discrimination against female sport
events Sports women has many forms we
need to make certain that more work is
done in this area getting rid of Ruby
Alice is a step forward and a very
important one but we can't just use a
repressive tactic we need to have
territorial networks which make sure
that women who are victims of abuse and
harassment are protected
we can't just stop here we need to
educate men in terms of emotional
education women aren't objects they're
not trophies to be shown as a sign of
power consensus is the only and consent
or the only criteria that count in sport
and elsewhere thank you
thank you the next speaker will be MS
yenbu
thank you
it's
um over and we need to stop with a
impunity it took three weeks before
lubious rubialis uh agreed to a step
down uh three weeks of condemnation from
everywhere but three weeks were not
enough to make him admit that his uh
just was unacceptable and was a sexual
harassment and that is the problem that
some people far too many people have not
yet understood but this is aggression
this is violence yes even for a stolen
kiss
um
it's not possible to justify these acts
and so I call on everyone we no longer
need to wait for those who are
propagating uh this violence to resign
you need to take the decision don't look
away be courageous and take the
decisions which are necessary to protect
the freedom and
um of women
um the shame needs to switch camps thank
you very much
and we can't find the colleague Ms
Miranda
in that case the next speaker will be
Miss bayerin ceresa
take your time
it's not your fault that the other
speaker is not there
please
I said I'm gonna give you a kiss and
okay
there's no notorious words have been
written in the history of sport they
represent the very worst of sexual
violence and discrimination against
women they Mark historical milestone
in our fight against wage discrimination
and the lack of technical support
however what happened led to a wave of
indignation and rejection in the country
a wave of female solidarity around the
world
which the leaders of the Spanish
Football Federation couldn't ignore
despite that however rubles did not
resign as we keep here it's all over now
this wasn't just a kiss it was no sexual
abuse and abuse of power that's a fact
however this is relevant way beyond the
world of football the similar problems
exist for women players of many sports
including young girls
as simple boys or Andre cautioning I've
also said
journalists politicians
waitresses also face similar problems we
have to bring an end to this culture of
impunity and what's happened this year
will be a talking point
the fact is today in this European
Parliament we've we're going to say once
again loud and clear it's over playing
in Carlsberg thank you very much the
next speaker is MS carlsbro
ok
president commissioner colleagues
um
all of those listening sometimes we hear
that what happens on the football pitch
or in the stadia OR in bedrooms is not
politics but of course it is a politics
that it's a societal issue that women
are discriminated against and attacked
and
and it beholds all of those in power to
change things uh football could have
said
uh
they could have uh as as she was then
accused that somehow she was at fault uh
I think this is a a traditional way that
the um blame is shifted uh football has
made great progress it's now a sport
which is for men and women but if girls
are too
um
be brave and tie up their football boots
we need to make sure that they will not
be subject to aggression
thank you very much the next speaker is
Miss herzberger for fun
six
thank you madam president sexism racism
homophobia just a few examples of the
Discrimination which
female sports players face
the most symbolic example of this is how
Afro-American
athletes in the 1960s Olympic Games in
Mexico raised Fists
the world's the Women's World football
cup has given exposed this whole
question the fourth case given by
rubialis has brought to the light of day
sexual violence this uh non-consensual
kiss was an example of sexual violence
we condemned this
this is another example of how high
level women athletes are seen the World
of Sport up until now their performance
wasn't uh considered to be as good as
that of men they were paid far less than
their male counterparts
there's lots of numerous examples of
inequality in women's sport they're not
there's training conditions are terrible
we also remember the debate about female
players wearing a veil who were subject
to all sorts of discrimination as well
this whole Scandal of the non-consensual
kiss
eclipsed the victory of those female
foot players no is no
and the president of the commission said
this yesterday we have to increase the
presence of women in the governing
bosses bosses of sports so that the
voice of women players can also be heard
it's finished
the women's silence a lack of respect no
is no and we have to bring an N2 to
impunity thank you come some catch the
eye thank you very much that bring us to
the catch the eye procedure there are
three requests which we can take and
we'll start with uh Mr uh Sean Kelly and
then Mr Garcia de Blanco
wow
iban you Iman you will be next in the
catch the eye who will still no okay all
right then please please microphone for
Sean Kelly 144.
thank you chair it's not often that we
have a debase in this Parliament around
uh sport
um or masters of sports in general and
therefore I greatly welcome this debate
this morning as it relates to the
Women's World Cup and at the outset I
have to say that the Women's World Cup
had a lot of positives uh the play was
very good there was very good skills
demonstrated
um and of course my own country Ireland
were also participating
um while they and they also gone on very
well but the manager although the
manager was since Departed the team but
of course
um some of this uh these positives have
been diminished because of the
um incidents that happened since then so
it shows that we have a long road to go
from now and that so that there is
equality between men and women in
sporting events but I hope that debates
such as this and and uh the my uh the
the various committees in the parliament
will help to achieve this uh goal gurma
thank you
now let me give the floor to Marlon
Burke thank you thank you very much
um and uh I would like to thank Jennifer
hermoso and the whole Spanish team also
those who actually boycotted and didn't
come to the World Cup uh I want to thank
them for the games I followed all of
them and you beat my country Sweden but
it was a very beautiful game
I want to thank you also because you are
role models on the field and off the
field and this is one of the reasons why
I love women's football
uh you play creatively strong powerful
games and then you walk off the pitch
and you continue to be role models and
you cannot wish for better
and there has been enormous support for
the Spanish team and and to denounce the
behavior of rubiales and bilda and the
others machos in the Spanish Federation
and let them all fall out now let them
all be gone in Spain and in elsewhere
where they are and let us continue the
fight for equality for you on the field
so that we can enjoy women's football we
will enjoy it next year for the Olympic
Games and we'll continue to enjoy it for
the world cup and for all the
generations to come you have shown the
way we will stand with you in solidarity
this is a me too for sports but all of
us know it's all over society and we are
behind you and with you you have our
backs
thank you very much and now for the
commission
uh commissioner Ferreira
Danke Schoen president and allow me for
a personal note just to say that um
in order when I can finish
honorable members thank you very much
for this debate it's really a debate on
civilization
in fact and now I speak on behalf of the
vice president sheenesh as I mentioned
and I strongly condemn all forms of
sexual harassment and violence in the
workplace
the sports field and everywhere else
weekend on you to make smooth progress
with your college letters on the
adoption of a directive on violence
against women
and domestic violence the adoption of a
strong and comprehensive directive on
violence against women and girls is the
best signal we can give
that we no longer tolerate violence we
want to combat and prevent sexual
harassment and violence in a holistic
way
let us ensure sport is a place of
victory for gender equality
thank you very much for your attention
and muchas gracias
well done to the world champions
thank you very much
that brings us to the next item on the
agenda which is the oral question to the
question on improving firefighters
working conditions
the um